da ist eine schwedische teenagerin die
im deutschen wahlkampf jetzt mitmischen
will mir gut das wisst noch jetzt
aufgreifen es gibt ja gar nicht um es
nur ein bisschen flapsig zu sagen ich
finde ich schon problematisch der seine
grünen demo pro grüne eine grünen
wahlveranstaltung mit einem sozusagen
showstar aus dem ausland zwei tage vor
der bundestagswahl vor dem reichstag
genehmigt wird das ist eine eindeutige
parteinahme für die grünen alle
berichten heute darüber wir haben ja
vorhin selber den kanzler alarm
ausgelöst und haben gesagt ja annalena
baerbock bei einer frei bis fünf user
demonstration das ist okay wenn sie sich
selber organisieren aber vor dem
reichstag dieses quasi
amtliche ja diese kulisse ist der
deutschland sozusagen diese bilder gehen
durch deutschland und um die welt am
zwei tage vor der wahl grünen demo für
die grünen ziele mit grünen politikern
die etwas sagen so viel einflussnahme
auf die wahl durch die
organisationsstruktur und durch die
genehmigung struktur habe ich selten
erlebt ich bin wirklich auch fassungslos
dazu noch gerät da also ich mein gerät
eine teenagerin das ist schön neutral
formuliert wie sich's gehört ich würde
mal sagen eine israel feindin die bei
der letzten großen kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen den angriffen der
hamas auf israel ganz klar parteiisch
war für die für hamas die hamas anliegen
tritt auf 48 stunden bevor in
deutschland gewählt wird also mir geht
es mit gibt es gar nicht im kopf dass
sowas genehmigt wird und das geht ja
eigentlich auch gar nicht nur um diesen
grundgedanken wir haben kaum
schülerinnen und schüler gesehen weil er
eine szene es ist eine
abschlusskundgebung der grünen am besten
platz den man haben kann genehmigt
durchchoreografiert bis in die großen
nachrichtensender hinein ich hätte heute
abend tagesschau aufmacher greta ist da
und so weiter das heißt doch mit anderen
worten liebe deutsche welt grün nur wenn
ihr grün welt geht es unserem land
weiter gut grün grün grün grün grün das
ist das was aus dieser veranstaltung
folgt und jetzt kann man sagen ja gut
wenn leute grün werden wollen sollen sie
halt grün wählen aber dieser jahrmarkt
der grünen ideen an diesem platz vor
diesem haus an diesem tag ist für mich
ein geht gar nicht wie du schon sagst
die organisation an sich was niemals die
eine seite die andere sache ist ob
annalena baerbock auch da hingeht und
sich da solidarisiert das plakat hält ja
annalena baerbock macht natürlich also
das würde ich an ihrer stelle auch mir
die sache zu eigen zu machen wenn ein
wiesel war es 400 orten in deutschland
oder 800 orten in deutschland jetzt
gerade wahlkampfveranstaltungen für mich
von anderen organisiert werden ist ja
wie ein heimspiel
wir stellen uns mal ganz kurz wir
stellen uns einmal 1 vor ich habe lange
überlegt ob ich sagen soll aber wir
stellen uns mal eins vor es wäre eine
solche veranstaltung
angekündigt gewesen und hätte um
genehmigung gebeten vor dem reichstag
unter der überschrift es kann nicht
jeder nach deutschland kommen also für
eine vernünftige flüchtlingspolitik ich
schwöre euch es wäre nicht genehmigt
worden mit genau der begründung zwei
tage vor der wahl nein politische
einflussnahme usw bei grün ist alles
egal dann wird der beste platz des
landes vor dem wichtigsten haus des
landes hergegeben für wahlwerbung und
das passiert in diesem land und es muss
man einfach einmal auch klar aussprechen
selbst wenn jetzt 20 prozent der
deutschen sagen hahahahaha der böse
konservative man ist hier ein bisschen
beleidigt dass die grünen eine gute idee
hat es ist ja gar nicht der böse
konservative mann sondern es ist die der
neutrale blick von außen wir haben heute
morgen die sendung hier begonnen und
haben das duell oder das septett von
gestern abend analysierte was du
derjenige der annalena baerbock jan in
einer regierung sehen würde der frischen
wind sehen will der einen neuanfang
sehen will gut da hatten will muss ich
sagen wir vielleicht noch vor augen
führen wir haben wir ein bild erzeugt
der herren söder scholz und lindner und
wenn ich nur dieses bild sehe dann sehe
ich persönlich zu viel gestern und da
ist es mir lieb dass frischer wind da
rein kommt also annalena baerbock ist da
kein vorwurf zu machen aber es ist ein
vorwurf zu machen denen die das
genehmigt haben denen die diesen platz
dafür hergegeben haben und hier kreta
hofieren als würde geräte selbst
antreten das fehlt ja gerade noch
[Musik]